Today we're going to talk about how to translate
high-level languages into code that computers
can execute.
So far we've seen the Beta ISA, which includes
instructions that control the datapath operations
performed on 32-bit data stored in the registers.
There are also instructions for accessing
main memory and changing the program counter.
The instructions are formatted as opcode,
source, and destination fields that form 32-bit
values in main memory.
To make our lives easier, we developed assembly
language as a way of specifying sequences
of instructions.
Each assembly language statement corresponds
to a single instruction.
As assembly language programmers, we're responsible
for managing which values are in registers
and which are in main memory, and we need
to figure out how to break down complicated
operations,
e.g., accessing an element of an array, into
the right sequence of Beta operations.
We can go one step further and use high-level
languages to describe the computations we
want to perform.
These languages use variables and other data
structures to abstract away the details of
storage allocation and the movement of data
to and from main memory.
We can just refer to a data object by name
and let the language processor handle the
details.
Similarly, we'll write expressions and other
operators such as assignment (=) to efficiently
describe what would require many statements
in assembly language.
Today we're going to dive into how to translate
high-level language programs into code that
will run on the Beta.
Here we see Euclid's algorithm for determining
the greatest common divisor of two numbers,
in this case the algorithm is written in the
C programming language.
We'll be using a simple subset of C as our
example high-level language.
Please see the brief overview of C in the
Handouts section if you'd like an introduction
to C syntax and semantics.
C was developed by Dennis Ritchie at AT&T
Bell Labs in the late 60's and early 70's
to use when implementing the Unix operating
system.
Since that time many new high-level languages
have been introduced providing modern abstractions
like object-oriented programming along with
useful new data and control structures.
Using C allows us describe a computation without
referring to any of the details of the Beta
ISA like registers, specific Beta instructions,
and so on.
The absence of such details means there is
less work required to create the program and
makes it easier for others to read and understand
the algorithm implemented by the program.
There are many advantages to using a high-level
language.
They enable programmers to be very productive
since the programs are concise and readable.
These attributes also make it easy to maintain
the code.
Often it is harder to make certain types of
mistakes since the language allows us to check
for silly errors like storing a string value
into a numeric variable.
And more complicated tasks like dynamically
allocating and deallocating storage can be
completely automated.
The result is that it can take much less time
to create a correct program in a high-level
language than it would it when writing in
assembly language.
Since the high-level language has abstracted
away the details of a particular ISA, the
programs are portable in the sense that we
can expect to run the same code on different
ISAs without having to rewrite the code.
What do we lose by using a high-level language?
Should we worry that we'll pay a price in
terms of the efficiency and performance we
might get by crafting each instruction by
hand?
The answer depends on how we choose to run
high-level language programs.
The two basic execution strategies are "interpretation"
and "compilation".
To interpret a high-level language program,
we'll write a special program called an "interpreter"
that runs on the actual computer, M1.
The interpreter mimics the behavior of some
abstract easy-to-program machine M2 and for
each M2 operation executes sequences of M1
instructions to achieve the desired result.
We can think of the interpreter along with
M1 as an implementation of M2, i.e., given
a program written for M2, the interpreter
will, step-by-step, emulate the effect of
M2 instructions.
We often use several layers of interpretation
when tackling computation tasks.
For example, an engineer may use her laptop
with an Intel CPU to run the Python interpreter.
In Python, she loads the SciPy toolkit, which
provides a calculator-like interface for numerical
analysis for matrices and data.
For each SciPy command, e.g., "find the maximum
value of a dataset", the SciPy tool kit executes
many Python statements, e.g., to loop over
each element of the array, remembering the
largest value.
For each Python statement, the Python interpreter
executes many x86 instructions, e.g., to increment
the loop index and check for loop termination.
Executing a single SciPy command may require
executing of tens of Python statements, which
in turn each may require executing hundreds
of x86 instructions.
The engineer is very happy she didn't have
to write each of those instructions herself!
Interpretation is an effective implementation
strategy when performing a computation once,
or when exploring which computational approach
is most effective before making a more substantial
investment in creating a more efficient implementation.
We'll use a compilation implementation strategy
when we have computational tasks that we need
to execute repeatedly and hence we are willing
to invest more time up-front for more efficiency
in the long-term.
In compilation, we also start with our actual
computer M1.
Then we'll take our high-level language program
P2 and translate it statement-by-statement
into a program for M1.
Note that we're not actually running the P2
program.
Instead we're using it as a template to create
an equivalent P1 program that can execute
directly on M1.
The translation process is called "compilation"
and the program that does the translation
is called a "compiler".
We compile the P2 program once to get the
translation P1, and then we'll run P1 on M1
whenever we want to execute P2.
Running P1 avoids the overhead of having to
process the P2 source and the costs of executing
any intervening layers of interpretation.
Instead of dynamically figuring out the necessary
machine instructions for each P2 statement
as it's encountered,
in effect we've arranged to capture that stream
of machine instructions and save them as a
P1 program for later execution.
If we're willing to pay the up-front costs
of compilation, we'll get more efficient execution.
And, with different compilers, we can arrange
to run P2 on many different machines - M2,
M3, etc. - without having rewrite P2.
So we now have two ways to execute a high-level
language program: interpretation and compilation.
Both allow us to change the original source
program.
Both allow us to abstract away the details
of the actual computer we'll use to run the
program.
And both strategies are widely used in modern
computer systems!
Let's summarize the differences between interpretation
and compilation.
Suppose the statement "x+2" appears in the
high-level program.
When the interpreter processes this statement
it immediately fetches the value of the variable
x and adds 2 to it.
On the other hand, the compiler would generate
Beta instructions that would LD the variable
x into a register and then ADD 2 to that value.
The interpreter is executing each statement
as it's processed and, in fact, may process
and execute the same statement many times
if, e.g., it was in a loop.
The compiler is just generating instructions
to be executed at some later time.
Interpreters have the overhead of processing
the high-level source code during execution
and that overhead may be incurred many times
in loops.
Compilers incur the processing overhead once,
making the eventual execution more efficient.
But during development, the programmer may
have to compile and run the program many times,
often incurring the cost of compilation for
only a single execution of the program.
So the compile-run-debug loop can take more
time.
The interpreter is making decisions about
the data type of x and the type of operations
necessary at run time, i.e., while the program
is running.
The compiler is making those decisions during
the compilation process.
Which is the better approach?
In general, executing compiled code is much
faster than running the code interpretively.
But since the interpreter is making decisions
at run time, it can change its behavior depending,
say, on the type of the data in the variable
X, offering considerable flexibility in handling
different types of data with the same algorithm.
Compilers take away that flexibility in exchange
for fast execution.